مرحبًا يا تشادويك ، إنه احتفال بالطماطم
لأنني أقوم بإعداد
فطيرة الطماطم للاحتفال
بالطماطم الكرز وجبتي الخفيفة المفضلة وسأحولها
إلى شيء سيكون المفضل لعائلتك ،
تعال معي في المطبخ أنا  سأوضح
لك كيف يتم صنعها
[موسيقى] ،
لذا فإن أفضل جزء في فطيرة الاحتفال هذه
هو أنه يمكنك تناولها طوال العام ،
وهذا يعني الذهاب إلى متجر البقالة ، لذا
لدي بعض النصائح لك
أولاً باختيار طماطم الكرز التي
تعرفها  لقد أحبهم الناس ورعاهم
، وهذه نصيحة علمني إياها جدي
عندما كنت طفلاً صغيرًا ، ثم
استخدم العبوة كمصفاة ، ببساطة قم
بتشغيلها تحت الصنبور وأنت انتهيت من
استخدام السكين المسنن ثالثًا ، إنها نظيفة  شريحة في
كل مرة واحدة من الأشياء التي تجعل
هذه الفطيرة لذيذة للغاية
هو أنها تحتوي على قشرة بسكويت الزبدة ،
تأخذ
كمين أسقطها في كيس كبير قابل لإعادة الغلق
، ثم سنقوم بسحقهم ليس
جيدًا لدرجة أنهم جميعًا فتات  لأن
تريد بعضًا من تلك القطع الكبيرة
وهذا ما يجعل قشرتنا لطيفة وضيقة ،
ثم سنضعها في وعاء
مع
الزبدة المذابة المملحة
وقليلًا من السكر البني
سنخلطها جيدًا حتى تريدها لطيفة
ورطب الآن سنأخذ
فتات البسكويت المبللة ونضعها في مقلاة مدهونة
10 × 15 ثم نخرجها
بالجزء الخلفي من الزجاج ونضعها في
الفرن
لمدة 10 دقائق عند 400 درجة.
الحشوة لطيفة
ومقرمشة حقًا بسيطة للغاية ،
لدي عبوتين من الجبن الكريمي
المخفف ، سأضيف بيضة واحدة
ونصف كوب من جبن البارميزان المالح
وقليلًا من المايونيز ، لا يوجد شيء
أفضل من الطماطم والمايونيز
.  سنمزج هذا معًا لمدة
دقيقة تقريبًا باستخدام الخلاط اليدوي
، ثم نملأ فطيرتنا
حتى تبرد قشرة الفطيرة وقم
بملئها بحشوة الكريمة
هنا حيث يبدأ الاحتفال بهذه الفطيرة
مع الطماطم الكرزية i  لقد حصلت على
مكايين من طماطم كرزية كاملة
و  نصف لتر واحد من استخدام
السكين المسنن لتقطيعها إلى نصفين ،
سأضيف بعضًا من زيت الزيتون الذهبي ،
والثوم المفروم جيدًا ، وبعض
الريحان الطازج ، وقليلًا من الملح
والفلفل ، سأقوم برمي هذا معًا لذا فهو
لطيف
ومغطاة بالزيت ،
سأجعل الفطيرة تضعها في الفرن عند
375 درجة لمدة 35 دقيقة وهي
مليئة بالنكهة
[موسيقى] ، كل
هذا خرج للتو من
الفرن ورائحته
طيبة جدًا قبل أن نبدأ  أكل النهاية النهائية
كان لدي بعض طماطم الكرز الطازجة
فوق هذا
بعض لحم الخنزير المقدد المنهار للحصول على لمسة blt وملوثات ضوئية
جميلة من
طماطم الكرز الحلو من الريحان من وجبة خفيفة إلى فطيرة
طوال العام
الآن وهذا شيء يستحق الاحتفال به
لمزيد من النصائح حول الوصفات وحيل المطبخ الرائعة
اذهب إلى chadwickboydlifestyle.com
أنت